[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the putative President of the
United States is not only being
investigated for illicit contact
directly or through intermediaries with
representatives of a hostile nation but
the head of the Federal Bureau of
Investigation reportedly asked the
Department of Justice to essentially let
him call the president
a lying gossip monger Trump's madness
and his weekend of channeling his
persecution complex and disseminating it
as a deflection from his own perfidy is
the obvious headline however the true
story is the moving parts of his regime
seeming treachery with Russia especially
those moving parts that have become the
wheels now flying off the vehicle to
dodge those wheels and review the
headlines as they land foremost
Trump's White House Counsel Don McGann
reportedly spent the weekend combing the
u.s. intelligence services trying to
gain access to any FISA Court ordered
surveillance related to Trump or his
associates that would be twice in a
little over one week that the White
House directly tried to interfere with
the investigation of the Trump gang and
Russia the first was when chief of staff
Priebus got the chairman of the House
and Senate Intel committees to spin the
media on Trump's behalf and then tried
to get intelligence officials to do the
same stuff like this is what Nixon's
White House tried to do with the FBI and
CIA throughout Watergate second headline
longtime trump confidant Roger stone
confessed
indeed publicly boasted over the weekend
of knowing in advance about the coming
WikiLeaks attacks on Hillary Clinton
last October I've never denied that
Assange and I had a mutual friend who
told me WikiLeaks had the goods on HRC
and would begin disclosures in acht
Assange does not work for Russians and
no one has proved otherwise although I
never had direct contact with him such
contact would be neither illegal or
improper even if stone is correct about
that this is damning circumstantial
evidence the most generous
interpretation is that a key Trump
adviser looked the other way before the
dissemination of emails stolen in what
the American intelligence community
search to this day was a Russian
cyberattack against this nation third
headline yes
attorney general and former Trump
campaign flunky sessions did the right
thing and recused himself from any
investigations of Trump and Russia but
he also gave a series of nonsensical
interview answers during the week asked
if anybody in the Trump campaign thought
the Russian government favored Trump
over Clinton sessions answered I have
never been told that the follow-up
startled question do you think they did
the sessions answer I don't have any
idea you'd have to ask them at his
confirmation hearing the one at which he
forgot to mention his meetings with the
Russian ambassador the subject of Russia
being guilty of interfering with our
election came up twice and sessions
first said at least that's what's been
reported and then said I have no reason
to doubt that and have no evidence that
would indicate otherwise sessions is
coming off as either a bad liar
paralyzed with guilt or a [ __ ] fourth
headline Carter page the second man
Trump ever mentioned is one of his
foreign policy advisers keeps changing
his story said on February 15th quote I
had no meetings no meetings with Russian
officials in 2016
said on March 2nd about meeting Russian
ambassador kis Lee act at the Republican
convention in Cleveland quote I'm not
going to deny that I talked with him
v headline Trump campaign national
security Lackey JD gordon changed his
story about how the Republican platform
at the convention was 180 from defending
Ukrainian rebels to kissing them off six
headline Michael Cohen Trump's personal
lawyer who has already changed his
Russian story at least four times did
not change it a fifth
however the businessman Alex Aronoff who
organized the controversial Ukrainian
peace plan that Cohen supposedly
hand-carried a general Flynn or enough
suddenly turned up all dead vii headline
whatever that is it's catching when the
popular ambassador to the UN Vitaly
Churkin killed over at his desk last
month he became the sixth Russian
diplomat to die suddenly since the day
Trump was elected eighth headline Trump
himself was reportedly so outraged by
the recusal of the Attorney General from
the Russian investigation that he went
into a three-day spasm of what about ISM
he began with a demand for an
investigation of this 2003 photo of
Senator Chuck Schumer and Vladimir Putin
which turned out to be them literally at
the ceremony christening the Russian
owned Lukoil service station in New York
City Schumer and Putin were at a gas
station ribbon-cutting like they were
the co-hosts of some radio station
morning sue program the ninth Trump
Russia headline Trump then tweeted the
first meeting Jeff sessions had with the
Russian AM was set up by the Obama
administration Trump added without
realizing was making his own argument
look ridiculous under education program
for 100 ambassadors when that didn't
work Trump moved on to repeating the
right-wing radio nutjob patter that
Obama had tapped
Trump's phone when that blew up in
Trump's face came the tenth headline the
reaction to the conflation of Russia
Obama and imaginary wiretap so screwed
up the White House that at 8:50 1:00
Eastern Time Sunday morning press
secretary Spicer declared that until
there was a congressional investigation
of Trump's crazy talk quote neither the
White House nor the present will comment
further 18 minutes later deputy press
secretary Sanders went on ABC's this
week to comment further and 25 minutes
after that Spicer commented further on
Twitter and by late Sunday afternoon
Trump was reported by Maggie Haberman of
the New York Times to have been quote
frustrated by the sunday shows today
felt people didn't defend him strongly
enough on his Obama claim / people close
to him and then at 7:06 Eastern Time
Monday morning the White House still not
commenting further commented further on
ABC again via the deputy press secretary
and lastly the 11th headline a question
posed in many different quarters
least seven Trump campaign figures had
contact with Russia even if every last
second of all the interaction was benign
did any of them at any time ask their
Russian pals if they would lay off the
International cybercrime all of this
one-to-one conversation and did anybody
in the Trump gang say you know you
should probably stop hacking our
computers and screwing with our
elections the wheels haven't just come
off the bus the tires have now formed a
pile and started a fire and of course
Trump who blamed the generals for the
loss of that Navy Seal in Yemen and
suggested the threats on Jewish centers
were made to arouse sympathy for Jews
none of this panorama of disloyal amoral
interaction with an enemy nation during
a presidential election none of this is
his fault and you know what Republicans
he's right this is no longer his fault
this is your fault look to our history
look to the Civil War when many
Democrats opposed intervention against
slavery and for personal politics and
the evils of inaction look to the years
before World War two when many members
of another political party the
Republicans opposed intervention against
Hitler and stuck to personal politics
and those evils of inaction what
happened to all those men they took the
fall not one prominent figure in either
party in either century survived the
political apocalypse that followed their
immorality they took the fall as all of
you gutless Republicans of today will
take the fall for enabling this treason
involving Russia to remain unrevealed
and this lunatic Trump to remain
unimpeached resist peace